this morning the white house put out a
study and that study claims the 400
wealthiest american families only paid
on average a federal tax rate of 8.2
percent now that's much lower tax rate
than historically we've heard and so
immediately that headline the 400
wealthiest american families only paid
eight percent federal tax
jumps off the page people say how's that
possible so
let's dig into the report first
first in the abstract kind of the
summary of it they say that they
estimate the average federal income tax
rate paid by american it's 400
wealthiest families using a relatively
comprehensive measure
relatively comprehensive measure keep
that in mind that'll be important later
of their income that includes income
from also unsold stock we do so using
publicly available statistics yada yada
whatever we estimate an average federal
income tax rate of 8.2 percent for the
period of 2010 to 2018. they also
present sensitivity analysis that yield
estimates in the six to 12 percent range
and they then proposals mitigate two key
contributors to the low estimated rate
uh including preferential tax rates on
capital gains and dividend income and
wealthy families ability to avoid paying
income tax on capital gains through a
provision known as stepped-up basis so
essentially what we have here is they
went they did a study
they claimed that they used relatively
comprehensive measure of income
and
the 400 wealthiest families paid 8.2
percent okay so far no red flags no
danger we are ready to rock and roll
next
piece
is when an american earns a dollar of
wages that dollar is taxed immediately
at ordinary tax income so we're starting
to get in some of the description here
but when they gain a dollar because
their stocks increase in value that
dollar is taxed at a low preferred rate
or never at all
and so what they're getting at here is
that the most common estimates of tax
rates do not fully capture the value of
this tax benefit because they use an
incomplete measure of income okay
getting a little weird
next
is how the wealthy enjoy low income tax
so now there's here's an explanation
preferred rates on an incomplete measure
of income
this is a study that was put up by the
white house that was done by economist
that says the wealthy pay low income tax
rates year after year for two primary
reasons
according to the white house and these
economists they say first much of their
income is taxed at preferred rates in
particular income from dividends and
from stock sales is taxed at a maximum
of 20
which is much lower than the maximum 37
ordinary rate that applies to other
income
second the wealthy can choose when their
capital gains income appears on their
income tax returns and never and even
prevent it from ever appearing if a
wealthy investor never sells stock that
is increased in value those investment
gains are wiped out for income tax
purposes when those assets are passed on
to their hairs under a provision known
as stepped up basis
and i think we have one last
piece of this here
is the study also
again they keep using this term
comprehensive measure of income
a preferred tax rate on income from
stock sales realized capital gains
income and from dividends feature
prominently in commonly cited tax rates
as well as in our analysis
an important feature of our analysis
that is less common in existing
estimates of tax rates is that we
include untaxed capital gains income in
our more comprehensive income measure as
they accrue all right
that's all what they said
i'm going to walk you through a couple
of different things here first of all if
i ask you what is the tax rate that
somebody pays and you tell me that they
made 100
and they paid ten dollars in taxes that
would estimate or that would be a ten
percent tax rate right made a hundred
dollars in income i paid ten dollars uh
in taxes i paid a ten percent tax rate
if i then go and say ah i don't actually
think you made a hundred dollars
instead i think you made
i don't know
five hundred dollars
and now that five hundred dollars you
actually only paid ten dollars in taxes
so you didn't pay ten percent tax you
actually only paid two percent tax
well
what
if i actually made a hundred dollars
originally that's what i reported to the
government and i paid ten dollars of
taxes on i had a ten percent tax rate to
use easy numbers and the government said
yep that's what you owed as you owed us
10
then i actually paid
10
to then go and inflate
the income based on other measurements
that are not currently how income is
defined
of course you're going to be able to say
people pay a lower rate this is this is
classic manipulation of data
which is the taxes that are owed based
on the current tax system end up being
one number and what this study does is
it goes and it says oh actually we're
going to drastically expand the
definition of income and we are going to
drastically expand the denominator in
this equation and therefore we're going
to artificially manipulate that number
down and then we're going to put a big
headline on a report and we're going to
publish it on the white house website
it's propaganda that's what this is this
is propaganda coming from the white
house
now
there's propaganda that works in both
ways
some administrations issue this stuff
and they say hey people don't need to
pay as much tax we should actually issue
tax cuts
other administrations like the current
one issue reports that say hey we should
tax people more so it's both political
parties engage in this stuff it just so
happens that the current administration
is trying to advocate for higher taxes
not lower taxes so the important parts
here
one
nobody is claiming including these folks
that the actual rate that was paid was
8.2 percent by the 400 wealthiest
american families
what they're actually saying is that if
we count differently
and then we apply what they paid so if
we take a uh a hypothetical amount of
income and then we apply what they
actually did pay then it would be 8.2
percent
but
if we actually said no we're going to
count differently the income and then we
applied the tax rates they would pay way
more than 8.2 percent so what you
essentially have is you're taking a fact
which is what they paid in aggregate
dollar amounts and then you're creating
a hypothetical income number and you're
trying to apply a fact to a hypothetical
to manipulate data to say what you want
it's intellectually dishonest now on top
of that
what this explicitly calls out first is
economists people who are academics
they no longer seek truth they no longer
seek the understanding of markets
they actually no longer even seek
accuracy
they merely have become political pawns
for both sides of the aisle
there are economists that are
manipulating data to tell us that
there's very high levels of inflation
and there's economists that are
manipulating data to tell us that we
shouldn't worry about inflation at all
there's economists that are manipulating
data to tell us that we should tax
everyone way more tax the rich burn it
all down take all their money
and then there's economists that are
manipulating data to say we should tax
nobody and if the federal government has
a spending problem
the truth is probably somewhere in
between
but what we can no longer rely on is we
cannot rely on economists because what
we have shown over and over and over
again is the data collection the data
sets and the methodology that goes into
these types of analysis are completely
flawed they fail any actual
pressure or logic
how is it that you can take what people
actually paid which the government has
said yes you paid me the right amount
and then hypothetically inflate the
amount of income that you wish that you
could count and then compare the two
things and then say oh by the way they
only paid 8.2 percent because if you go
look at the tax returns the actual
documents of what those families paid
it's not 8.2 percent it's something much
higher now we can debate whether they
should be paid more
or less than what they actually paid
that's fine that's a that's a fair
debate and one that is is playing out
right now but what you can't say is that
they actually paid 8.2 percent it's
intellectually dishonest and i would
even go as far as to say it's inaccurate
now on top of that
this all comes down to something called
unrealized capital gains the idea of
unrealized capital gains is if i take a
hundred dollars and i buy a stock and
that stock appreciates and let's say
that stock goes from 100
all the way up to 500 in value now so i
put a hundred dollars in the system as
an investment that company
used that money to go and create jobs to
build products and services to pay their
employees to pay taxes to the government
etc
they then
are able to increase the value of their
business
and my share in the company is not worth
a hundred dollars anymore it's not worth
500. i'm a great investor
i have not yet sold that stock
and so what unrealized capital gains
means
is that i went from a hundred dollars to
500 i have 400
of unrealized gain
if i was to sell the 500 stock now
i would take back my hundred dollar
principal plus 400
of
gains that would be realized capital
gains and i would be taxed when i sell
that stock
so what essentially they are trying to
get at here is they are trying to count
unrealized capital gains
as income
now there's an entire push in certain
parts of the economy by certain
economists by certain politicians
certain social groups etc to tax
unrealized gains
now to give you a sense of how idiotic
and stupid this would be the u.s stock
market the s p 500 is up 30 plus percent
in the last 12 months
that means that for every dollar
that has been invested over the last
year
every single person in the stock market
owes
30
percent give or take depending on how
you count short-term long-term capital
gains 20
is long-term something higher is
short-term i avoid
short-term capital gains
and so now all of a sudden if it's up 30
that means that every single american
who owns a us-based stock
would have to sell some of their stocks
to pay
for the gains that the stock market gave
them you would disincentivize people
from investing
it would be a complete
new addition of friction
on top of that
you start to look at things like
every single american who owns a home
home prices are up double digits over
the last 12 months
every single american if you owned a
home and it was 200 000
and let's say your home is now worth 300
000
you don't know that for sure but it kind
of sort of looks like that based on
comps in your area
if your house appreciated 50 in the last
year
and you owe taxes
from a 200 to 300 000 home value it's a
100 000 in unrealized gains
that means you owe 30 000
plus or minus depending on the exact tax
rate you get hit with
where are americans going to come up
with that
90 of americans don't even have enough
money to pay for retirement
let alone every year to pay the
government because the home that they
purchased went up in value unrealized
capital gains is about the dumbest
economic
idea
that we've ever seen
because also we never hear about
unrealized capital losses
if i was to buy that stock at 100
and rather than it go to 500
instead it actually went down by 50
percent and that hundred dollar stock
was now only worth fifty dollars
nobody's talking about giving me fifty
dollars in losses
if i don't sell the stock
so how is it that the unrealized capital
gains
is in the crosshairs
but we don't want to give the same
treatment to the people who make an
investment and if they lose money in an
unrealized basis they get the benefit of
the loss
it's because this has nothing to do
with fairness it has nothing to do
with trying to actually create an
economic system that incentivize
investment in innovation job creation r
d etc
no what it's about is simply punishing
success
condemning success
taking from those people who have done
something
eighty percent of u.s
millionaires
inherited zero dollars
they built
their wealth they did not inherit it
eighty percent
thirty three percent of millionaires in
america never made more than a hundred
thousand dollars
so now those people who have been
investing their entire lives we're gonna
punish them for being disciplined for
spending less than they make staying out
of debt buying long-term assets and
holding them you completely
disincentivize capitalism
and we have example after example after
example in history of socialism
absolutely not working
on top of that are we just going to have
national crash the stock market day
is that what we're actually advocating
for
is the tens of millions of americans who
are invested in the u.s stock market
when it comes to paying unrealized
capital gains we're all gonna go to the
stock market take a couple of shots of
liquor and then just pull on the wheel
and hope to god that when we all sell at
the same time to be able to get money to
pay the tax man that we don't crash the
stock market
this is insanity
and frankly
it's disappointing to see
the white house publish something like
this now my favorite part about this
also is this thing idea of stepped-up
basis
and so let's say that john and i
were not brothers brothers in arms and
brothers in blood
instead
john and i
were father and son
whoa
and i
was an amazing investor and i bought all
these assets through my life and towards
the end of my life
i went ahead and i wrote a will and in
my will i said you know what
my kid is in a deadbeat he's actually
pretty smart
i want when i die him to make the
decisions as to what happened to my
assets
this is a pretty normal activity for
almost everyone in the world what
happens when i die
now when i die
let's say that i had a piece of real
estate that piece of real estate i
bought for a hundred dollars it is now
appreciated over the la my lifetime and
it's worth a thousand dollars
when john inherits that piece of real
estate
rather than the cost basis of the real
estate being a hundred dollars
the cost basis now goes up to a thousand
dollars he inherited it and so there's a
step up
in the cost basis john's cost basis is a
thousand dollars my cost basis was a
hundred
now the reason why we do that is because
if john ever goes to sell the real
estate
john and let's say now it's worth
uh fifteen hundred dollars john will pay
taxes on his five hundred dollar gain
from a thousand to five hundred uh to
fifteen hundred dollars
he still has to pay taxes when he sells
it at a profit
but that step up basis is one thing that
we are talking about here
now if you read this you would be
remiss
to think
are wealthy people
so worried about taxes that their tax
strategy
is to die
is that really the tax strategy that
we're claiming wealthy people are taking
is that i want to save money from paying
taxes so badly
that i'll die
it's not like wealthy people are off in
the corner committing suicide to prevent
paying taxes
it's not like they're telling hey john
you want this real estate kill me dog
like i gotcha no
death
is inevitable
and so we can argue and debate over how
we treat assets
should john
have to pay taxes based on a gain from a
hundred dollars to fifteen hundred
dollars or should john have to pay taxes
from the thousand dollar stepped up
basis to fifteen hundred dollars
those debates are fine
but to insinuate that
older people
wealthy people are literally planning
death in order to avoid paying taxes is
ridiculous
and so when you start to look at
the stepped-up basis
what you have to ask yourself is
are we trying to punish dead people
or are we trying to incentivize
those that are inheriting the assets
to continue to invest
in whatever the assets are the entire
point of the tax system is it serves as
a carrot
and a stick
you can manipulate the tax code to
incentivize investment now on top of
that
i don't think that we have the political
will nor do i actually believe the
people who are saying that they're going
to institute unrealized capital gains
taxes
because guess what
the multi-millionaires
who
run the current administration
joe biden estimated to be worth 10 plus
million dollars
kamala harris estimated to be worth
millions of dollars
and also
many of the other elected congressmen
and senators
they're not going to sell their stock
every year to pay the tax either
this isn't about the little guy and it's
not about the big guy it's about simply
understanding
if
you want to incentivize investment
incentivize economic prosperity and
incentivize innovation
you can't have a system
that punishes people for successfully
investing
throughout this entire report
it says wealthy people wealthy people
wealthy people
they don't have a special tax code
these rules apply
to the richest person
and to the poorest person in america
they are the rules
the difference is not the amount of
wealth they have
the difference is
information so rather than complaining
about this rather than sitting there and
pointing at the people who have taken
the time or used the resources to get
the information and figure out how to
use this to their advantage
instead what we should be telling people
is you can do this too
you can use these exact same rules
and you can use the tax code
in order to benefit from it
there's no difference between jeff bezos
buying stock
and holding it as it goes up and not
paying tax on that wealth creation
then you doing the same thing you can go
to sofi.com
you can buy a stock and if it goes up
500 percent you won't pay taxes either
until it is sold
that's the tax code
so it's not a oh the wealthy people are
doing something nefarious or malicious
it's just that we have a financial
education gap in this country
they are educated on this stuff and
everyone else isn't
and so rather than trying to take from
the people who figured it out
the entire point of this show is that we
should go and we should ask every single
person who figured it out how'd you do
it hey guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today
and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com pomp download the app and go
ahead and open an account sofi.com pomp
and make sure you come back and watch
more of the best business show we're
going to build the biggest business show
in the world and we need your help
[Music]